今日は最終回で道徳について
非常に必要な情報は繰り返するかもしれませんが
一応道徳論ということで
世の中であんまり道徳という問題はそんなに誰も発信してないし
仏教はそれをしっかりとしていますから
それはどういうことか
ですから 今日は特にブッダの道徳について語りたいと思います
だから明確な道案内なんですね
で 今日そういう項目は6つに分けてやります
その本を読んでいると思っちゃえば
小さな書冊を1つ読んでいるんだという感じで見てみればいいと思います
ちょっと今日遅くなったからいろいろミスはあると思いますけど
第一にモラルモラル設定の背景と権威ということ
それから 2番目に誰でも戒めるべき内面ということ
3番目 道徳的行動 それは 2つに分けます
不変面と可変面 可変面という
まあ私は勝手に作った言葉で間違ってるかもしれませんけど
変化できない側面と変化できるという意味なんですね
例を言えばインフレデフレということとか
で 道徳と例外例外っていうのはどうなりますか？例外の危機
例外に立てる範囲 社会との調和というところで考えています
5番目に 理性知恵と道徳は不可分的な関係であるということを説明します
最後に何のための道徳かという
で 最後にいっぱい経典を並べようかなと思ったんですが
時間が間に合わなかったです
これから進んでいきます
で  第1章 モラル設定の背景と権威 Background Authority of moral thoughts ということ
背景の authority
なぜ道徳戒律などが必要でしょうかということ
なんで人間にこんなに道徳戒律がいるもんかという問題もあります
で そういうことに それから答えを探そうと思います
それで認識を漏らすということで必要性
道徳っていうのは必要であるという結論なんですね
我儘で生きることで他人に迷惑をかける
だから我々は我儘で生きてるんだから
我々は他人に迷惑をかけている
そうすると まあいいんじゃないかなんてね
もう他人に迷惑をかけろ
私は知らんでしょうという感じ出すかもしれませんが
他の人は我儘だから自分に迷惑をかけるでしょ
それ嫌でしょう 自分が迷惑をかける分はまあへっちゃらなんですけど
でも他人の我儘で自分に迷惑ですから
やっぱり道徳っていうのは必要になるんですよ
自分でも幸福になりたいが
自分が選ぶ道は逆効果をもたらす
それで一人一人の人間が幸福になりたい
幸福になるためにいろいろ道を選ぶんですよ
あれしましょう これしますとやってます
しかし 人間というのは何やっても幸福になるんじゃなくて
逆に不幸になってしまうんです
だから誰かが正しい道案内をしてくれないと幸福にはなりっこない
そういうわけで 道徳っていうのはものすごく必要なんです
それ単純に聞こえるかもしれませんだけど
この哲学世界では大変な問題なんです
道徳はなんで必要なのかと
あんまり誰も考えたことがないと思いますけど
仏教の答えは人間は幸福になりたいが
その方法はわからない
人が何か選んでやっちゃうと結局は不幸になってしまう
だったら教えてあげなくちゃいけないでしょう
だから幸福になる道を教えてあげなくちゃいけないことになります
互いに決まりを守ることで社会の秩序を保たれる
それで我々はお互いに決まりがあって
その決まり守っていると
お互いに社会はうまくいくんですよ
決まり守らないと社会成り立ちませんね
そういうわけで必要になるんです
次に ガイドラインがあった方が人に成長しやすい
我々に生きるガイドラインがあった方がやりやすいんですよ
何もなく地図もなくても
森を探検しなさいと言っても
もうできるわけないぐらいなるんですよ
だから何か地図みたいなガイドラインがあった方が生きることは楽になるんです
どうすれば幸福になるのかと明確にした方が良い
そこで仏教の道徳っていうのは幸福になる方法っていうことで
それははっきり理解した方がいいんですよ
こういうことをしたらこうなるんだよと
今日はそこを説明する暇がないと思いますが
心の本能は悪を犯すようになっている
それはずっと説明しました
我々の心はもう悪を犯したくてたまらん状態にいるんですよ
だから放っておくともう何するかわからない
平気で悪を犯しちゃいますけど
結局それで自分が破壊される
今は しかし 心は道徳を犯したくて犯したくて
悪いことをしたくてしたくて
もうもうたまらないんですよ
心にそういう本性があるんです
だからそれはすごいはっきりと厳しく鎖をかけておかないと
自分が自己破壊する 我々は自己破壊に行くような心を持っているんです
そういう理由で 道徳っていうのはもう欠かせない
必ずもう必要なものです
ただ 今の若い方々が言うように
人は勝手に作ったものでしょうとかね
そんなものじゃないんです
人間勝手に作ったものでもなく
それはもう呼吸することと同じく必要なものなんです
そういうことで まああまり難しくないんだから
先に進んでいきます それからオーソリティーということ
権威ですね では 道徳を設定する権利は誰にあるんでしょうか
人間に道徳を定める権利は誰にあるのでしょうか
それはすごい大事な問題なんです
例えば国会には法律を作る権利があるでしょ
だから国会で新しい法律を作ったら
こちらではもうどうすることもできなくした方がしかないんです
国会のその権利があるんです
で まあ比較して言うなれば
イスラム教やらキリスト教やら
もう絶対的な神様は信仰しているんだから
この神様にその権利があるんですね
人間にああしろこうしろという権利は
仏教になってくると大変ですよ
神様が認めませんから
社会では管理者が管理される側に対して規則などを設定しているのです
社会では管理者が偉い人がそうでない人々にいろんな命令して規則を作るんですね
例で言えば 子供の村を親が決め
随分勝手に親があれしなさいこれしさいとかね
あれやったらあかん これやったらあかんと
子供は弱いんだからね
どうすることもできんだからね
管理されてるんだから
もう守るしかないんですね
それがもう社会でも同じこと
国会は国民に法律を定めるとか
そういう風に権利がある
権限があるんですね 宗教の場合は人間に関係のない神だけになる
宗教の世界では神が道徳を決めるんです
[音楽]だと言ってるんです
しかし このモラルを守るべき側も異論反論を持つこともあり
守ってもらうことも大変です
これは現実ですよ 例えば神様が道徳決めたと言っても
神様は信仰している方々は誰も守ってないんです
なんとかしてこの道徳を侵す
もう穴ばっかり探してるんです
例えばイスラム教ではもう自殺してはいけないんですよ
もう 直行地獄に落ちるんです
なのに なんとかもう理由作るんですよ
自殺 もうテロ行為やさせるために
一人で死んだら地獄に落ちるんだけど
たくさんの人を道連れにすれば天国やったいう
もうわけもわからない理屈ですけど
で キリスト教も同じで
殺すなかれとは書いてますよ
なのに キリスト教の歴史の中でどうすれば殺せるのかということしか考えてないんです
だから こういうわけだったら戦争してもいい
ああいうわけだったら戦争してもいいという風にも
せっかく神が言った道徳なのに
それさえも守らない人間が国家
国の法律ぐらい守ると思いますかね
だから我々はいいんだけど
神様は信仰している人々っていうのはもう真剣
真面目に信じてくれなきゃダメでしょうに
そういう そ-そこまで権利つけてるんですけど
人っていうのはもう否定しちゃうんですね
道徳を だからまあそこら辺で見えることは
なんで人間に反論できるのかと
権利あるんだったら反論できないはずなんですよ
例えば皆様があの 私は何て言いますか
税金払いませんよとかね
それ言われることできるでしょ
気持ちはどうであって
法律だから 払わなくちゃいけない
それははっきりした権利あるんですよ
権利は 国家に そこはもう道徳の世界でないんですね
人間っていうのは異論立てますよ
反論するんですよ というのは
この道徳っていうのはいい加減で
権利あると言ったってもろくな道徳言ってないんですよ
例えば聖書で殺すなかれと言ってるんだけど
なぜなのかとは言ってないんです
自分が平気で殺すんです
私が行くところには 血やら涙やらもう伝染病やらもうもう何だかんでもあるんだぞとかね
血を流したい放題流してやるぞとかね
そういうことだから もう例えばヒンドゥー教っていうのはすごい非暴力主義でしょ
って言いながら ヒンドゥー教の聖典なんか戦争の本なんですよ
全部 もう戦いを正当化しながら非暴力主義でやりましょうっていうのはなかなか成り立たないんですね
だからいい加減曖昧なんですよ
だから道徳も調べる哲学世界だけでも
道徳っていうのはすごくもうややこしくて
もう理由はわからなくなっちゃって
なんででしょうかと なぜ嘘ついてはいけないのかと
なぜ殺してはならないのかと
これ答えがないんですよ
だから仏教っていうのはものすごいもう徹底して調子してほしいな
道徳論は 誰にも文句言えないようにしっかりと立ってるんです
はい 権利は続きます 仏教は生命は平等でありという立場をとる
生命は平等 人間は平等じゃないんです
生命は平等だよ そう言っちゃうと権利はないんですよ
誰にも 平等だから あんた何様のつもりですか？と言えるんですよ
嘘をつくな あんたなんで嘘をついてるんでしょうか？とか言われると
あんた何様のつもりですか？と
だって平等でしょう 嘘をつくがつかないか私の勝手やと
いうことを言えますよ
生命平等だけ言うと 神の絶対的な権利を持つ存在は
なんとか間違ってるみたいです
存在をありえないとしている
神のようなね 絶対的な権利を持つ存在はありえないとしています
仏教はありえないと言うんです
神様否定するんじゃなくて
こんな絶対的な存在 生命の親分なんかはね
こんな世にありえないんだと
平等だからっていうこと
そうしちゃうと一番難しいのは仏教ですよ
キリスト教の方々には神様がこう言ったと言っちゃえばそれで済みますからね
モーセの十戒もそうでしょう
本人が病気ということは
当時で精神病気という概念もなかったし
そんな言う必要もないし
私は神様が言いましたと
言っちゃえばそれで終わっちゃうんです
神様は神様で公で言わないんですね
怖くて 怖いかな 地球上にみんなに聞くのに言っちゃえばもう絶対的でしょう
だからまあそれでもその宗教には道徳設計することは簡単ですが
仏教にはものすごい難しいんですよ
生命は平等という立場
では仏教はどうやっているのかと見てみましょう
過去 皆各自の業によって生きているので
偉大なる存在にも他の生命に対して何かを決める権限はないはずです
例えば偉大なる生命はいますよ
我々人間平等だと思っても
実際はもうそうでもないしね
我々はものすごいごっつい偉い方々がいるでしょうに
総理大臣もいるし もう閣僚もいるし
もう天皇陛下もいるし
ものすごい偉いんですよ
だからといって人間平等ですよ
偉いんだからといっていい加減好き勝手に人間に何か言うことはこれはできませんよ
憲法で法律ではね もう総理大臣には全部権限があるんだけど
あるんだからといって使うことはできません
だから例えば神がいるとしても
そいつにはその権利がないんですよ
私はもう神だからあんた方のことよく知ってるんだぞとかね
だからこうしなさい ああしなさい
権利はないんですよ なぜならば
神は自分の業によって神になっただけで
業が消えちゃうと もうパーだから別な生命になっちゃいますから
そんな偉そうなことを言うなよと
総理大臣でいるのは まあそこでまあ国会の寿命があるだけの話で
国会解散したらもう全部終わっちゃうでしょうに
それも業と同じなんですよ
だからこの乱用はできないという立場なんです
したがって 嘘つくなかれなどを他人に言う権利は誰にもありません
よく覚えてください 嘘を言うなよとか
人を殴るなよとか 人のもの盗るなよとかね
そんな言う権利は誰にもないんです
仏教から見れば 人間は平等
自分は自分の業によって生きているんです
業は自分がやったこと
だから自分がすごい偉い状態で生まれてるんだと
それは自分のやり方 結構いいの結果で自分がものすごい惨めにいるんだったら
それはそれで自分が勝手にやった行為の結果である
他人にごちゃごちゃ言う権利はないんです
時々いるでしょうに まああいつよりなっているから
なんであんたそんなに
それは俺の勝手だよという人がいるでしょうね
放っておけと でも正しいんですよ
なんで支出入りの否定ですか？ではないんです
言葉正しいんです 放っておけないんだよと言ったら大きなお世話でしょうに
だから親子関係で必ず失敗する
そういうわけ 放っておけない
道徳を課してますよ 親も
子供にいちいち言う権利はないんです
だからどうすればいいんですかね
仏教は大変な状態になるんですね
そうなってくると はい
次に行きます しかし 科学者のものの見方を借りて観察しましょう
で 本当はこれ逆なんですよ
科学は最近現れたもので
仏教のものの見方はものすごい昔からあったもので
しかし もうやけに似ているんです
でもちょっと科学なめた人々は
もうなんか科学こそがすごく偉いんだと
あんた方も科学者にチャレンジする勇気あるってことはすごいことだと呼んでる
逆なんですけど 医学者は
だってこれ例なんです
医学者は細菌に感染すればどのような病気にかかるかを発見する
何でもいいんです 一般的な例だから
例えば医学者がいて いろいろ細菌の研究をして
この細菌に感染すれば
こういうこういう病気になるとしっかりと発見する
研究の結果で感染ルートも対処方法も発見する
その医学者はもう感染ルートもその感染したらどうすべきか
感染しないためにどうするべきかと全部発見する
それを皆の健康を心配してこれこれする中で感染したならこのような対処をしなさいという
自分が発見した事実だから
みんなのことを心配して言うだけであって
医学者の話を聞いただけで我々の権利なくなった？なくなったわけじゃないんです
ただ 我々は知らないことを教えてくれただけです
かえって感謝するしかないでしょうに
それである真理を発見したからそれを言う権利があります
地球が丸いと発見したら黙っていてはいけないんですよ
みんなに言わないことにしようと
私だけの秘密にしようと
もうバカバカらしいんですよ
地球が丸いと発見したところで
それは堂々と発表する
誰の権利を奪ってないんです
その人殺されちゃったんですけど
だから真理を科学世界でよくやってるんでしょうに
事実を発見して それをみんなに言おう
それだけのことで 遊びにいきます
支配するされるという問題ではなく
健康を維持するために規則が現れてくる
医者の例 医者が我々を支配しているわけじゃなくて
まあみんな健康でいたいんだから
それで規則が成り立つんですよ
権利の問題じゃないんです
道徳基準もこのような立場で語るべきものです
だから道徳基準もそういう風に語らないと
例えば冬になってくるとまあインフルエンザウイルスが広がりそうとかね
医者は先に言うんですよ
もう香港の方で 台湾の方で何かインフルエンザが出てくると
あ これは必ず日本にも来るんだよと
まあ知ってるんです それで我々の権利なくなったわけじゃないでしょう
SARSウイルスの場合はね
もうものすごい日本はすごい厳しく管理したでしょうに
日本に入らないように
やっぱりそれで不幸にならずに済んでしまったし
しかし 鳥のウイルスは一応鳥インフルエンザは入ってしまったんですけど
それもみんな道徳を犯したんだからでしょ
インチキやろうと思ったんだからでしょ
それで道徳がなかったならば
特に京都の方でね もう
ひどい目に遭ってしまったんですね
支配者本来はいないが
本来は支配者はいません
が 決めるものではありません
道徳っていうのは支配者が決めるものではございません
しかし 仏教から見れば支配者なんかいるわけじゃないんです
みんな平等です 日本の総理大臣は皆様を支配しているわけじゃないんです
ただ総理という仕事をしているだけ
互いに話し合って決められるものでもありません
これも覚えておいてください
道徳というのはお互いに話し合って決めるものじゃないんです
科学技術と同じものなんです
例えばウイルスに感染すると言ったら話し合う余地がないでしょうに
あの何でしたっけ？牛肉の場合はあの狂牛病はね
まああの BS なんでしたっけ？ BSE BSE は肉食べても感染する恐れがある
別に話し合いの余地がないでしょう
あれはウイルスでもないし
細菌でもないし あの何でしたっけ？ある一つのプロテインですね
タンパク質との一緒なんです
だから煮ても焼いてもどうにもならん
感染する恐れがある だからその話し合いの余地がないんです
食べないということになっちゃいます
だから道徳っていうのでは
我々みんなで決断してこうしましょうということじゃないんです
道徳の場合 はい また権限続きます
生命に対する真理を発見した人
幸福とは何かと発見した人
幸福を得る方法を発見した人
またその道が正しいと実証した人にだけ道徳を決める権利があるのです
本当は権利ではなくて権威ですね
だからみんなに嘘を言うなかれという権利はないんです
あるのはその科学者にだけ
どんな科学者というと
生命に対する真理 丸ごと発見した人
幸福って何なのかと明確に科学的に発見したならば
それから幸福になる方法をしっかり発見したならば
またその法は正しいと実証している
いろいろ研究 それだったらその方にのみ発表する権利があります
科学と丸っきり同じ したがって
道徳とは悟った人が他人に教える
教えてあげる正しい生き方なんです
悟ってない人が言うことは道徳ではございませんよ
大変なことになりますね
その場合が 僕はその時点で凄い厳しいんです
誰にも権利がないんです
しかし ブッダに権利があるんです
なぜならば ブッダが公で宣言しています
私は真理発見しました
不死なる道を見つけた
不死なる境地に至った
だからしょうがないんです
これが方法だよと言うしかないんです
それは偉大なる科学者で
ブッダの義務でもありまして
責任でもあります 科学者が地球が丸いと発見したら
それ言って隠すわけにはいきませんでしょう
隠しちゃうととんでもないことでしょう
時々ありますよ いろんな薬やらいろんなもの発展しますよ
隠しちゃいます もっと金儲かろうと
日本でもあの血液製剤
なんとか何とかでね 加熱処理してない
と病気になりますよという情報はもう随分前来ていたパターンです
アメリカから送ってくる
危ない しかし 日本では加熱処理しないで薬を作っている
これ工場を新しく作るためには時間かかる
そこまで黙っていよう
こんなのは科学者やること？犯罪者でしょ
人殺しちゃった まあ日本はそんなに犯罪者扱いされてないんですけど
まあ一応我々から見ればそれ人殺しです
あのお医者様がデータ隠したこと
だから科学者は真理発見したらすぐ一般の人に言うべきなんです
だからお釈迦様が真理発見したんだから言っただけのこと
別にお釈迦様は我々の自由を奪ってないんです
しかし 私の結論は 道徳を語る権利権限はブッダにしかありません
ブッダでなければ悟った人に誰にでもあります
はい しかし ブッダにさえも守りなさい
従いなさいというと命じることはできません
人間平等だから 生命平等だから
言うだけ 命じることはできません
医者はこれこれ食べるなよとかね
こういう風なことをしちゃうと
このウイルスに感染するぞと言うだけ
こちらにはもう法律でそれをやるなけれという権利はないんです
こちらが勝手にやって病気になったら
それはこちらの責任 はい
生命は平等なので 自己責任で守るものです
道徳っていうのは いつでも自己責任で守るものです
貪瞋痴の感情がある人は
決める道徳に たとえその人が偉くても異論立てることはできます
人間作る道徳には異論立てられます
人間には貪瞋痴があるんだから
だから皆様は自分の母親がいろんなことを言うと
ずーっと文句言うでしょ？反発するでしょ
異論立てられます 母親も知って言ってるわけじゃないんだから
母親にも貪瞋痴はあるし
もうわかってるわけじゃないし
ただ言うだけ道徳を だから子供はそれには反発する
反発する権利もある だから世の中の道徳には
人間というのはなんだかんだでもやっぱり反発はするんです
だから どんな偉い人が世の中道徳を語っても
我々は 我々にはそれに異論を立てる権利があります
ブッダには異論を立てる権利はないのです
ブッダの道徳は提示であって命令ではないので
異論を立てる余地はありません
ブッダはただ提示するだけです
地球が丸いと言うような感じで
もしそれ事実だったら
もう異論はないんです
だからそのチャレンジはお釈迦様は挑戦は出すんですよ
チャレンジ もし嘘だったら言ってみなさい
できるわけないんだよ
誰に 貪瞋痴の人に決して異論
論理的に異論を立てることも不可能なんです
ブッダの道徳には異論を立てることっていうのは絶対不可能です
お釈迦様こう言ってもとかね
それは言えません まあいい加減には言えますけど
きちんと科学的に論理的には言えないんです
はい それで 仏教だから仏教徒は 2つの立場をとるんですよ
仏教の道徳は仏教独自なものではなく
普遍的な道徳なのです
仏教の道徳は仏教徒だけ守る
ある特定の宗教のものじゃない
これは普遍的に正しいことと正しくないことということ
信仰に関わらず 人を誰でも守るべきもの
信仰関係ない ブッダ昇華者に説かれたものはすべて個に気に入るか気に入らないか
納得いけるかないかも関係なく道徳なんです
個人個人には気に入るか気に入らないか
それは関係ないのです
ブッダに説かれたら これがもう道徳です
守るしかないのです それは仏教徒はその 2つの立場
道徳は普遍的である ブッダに語られたものは一切道徳である
世間で認めるモラルでもブッダは否定するなら非道徳なんです
それも覚えてほしいんです
世間では正しい正しいと言うことでも
ブッダの教えに当てはめてみると正しくないとわかったら
世間の人類みんな言っていたっても正しくない
どう見たっても正しくない
ブッダに言われると もうもう最終的な答えなんです
それがもう仏教の道徳っていうのはすごい厳しい
なぜならば道徳っていうのは実際人間やるものなんですよ
厳しくないといけない
人々と遊んではいけませんよ
人の命とは 他のことだったら
お互いに話し合ったり
討論したり それはもう知識遊びは別に乗ったことないんです
これ知識遊びじゃないんです
実際の人がの生き方なんです
だから人の命とは遊ぶんじゃない
ものすごい真剣にしっかりと左か右か
まっすぐかと言ってもらわないと
そういうわけで 道徳っていうのはものすごい厳しい
もう絶対的に誰にも何とも言うことはできない
だからこの時点では個人の好みとかはね
全然相手にしない 例えば私は酒が好きや
あんた好きかろうが嫌かろうが関係ないんだよ
それは悪いものだ 私には嘘をつけないと生活
生計を立てませんと 勝手にやってください
しかし 嘘をつくものは不幸になるんだよ
それは法則だよ 決まってる
ということで 甘く見てあげることはしないんですね
なのにみんな私にいろいろ質問するんです
すごく厳しいんですよ
昨日もね 自分が酒なんとか人に勧める仕事をしてるんだから
まあまあどうしようかとかね
こんなことを私に聞いたって
もう私は道徳の師してますからね
答えようもないんです
実際に聞かれたことがないんですけど
漁師は私の仕事は漁師ですけど
殺生は守れませんよと言っても答えようもない
その人の危険とあんたならしょうがないんだよ
そんなこと言ったって
もう殺される魚に命あるでしょ
そんな知ったものじゃないんですよ
漁師にはもう家族守れませんよと
誰が言ったんですか？生命尊重
家族守れと 誰も言ってないでしょうに
自分が選んだんだから
それで殺し屋がいるでしょ
プロの プロの殺し屋がお金くれるから人を殺す
それでその人が私のところに来て
これは私の仕事ですよ
そんなこと言っても  いや
弁護士が嘘をつくとでしょ
これは仕事だからしょうがないと
それはできません だったら弁護士辞めろ
そうしても世界で弁護士がなくなったら困るし
そんなちったあもんじゃない
だって人は嘘をつかなかったら弁護士いらんでしょうに
結局は だってこれなんですけど
人嘘を言うんだから弁護士を立てるし
もう立てたところでそいつはまた嘘を言うし
そこで裁判所っていうのは真実のみを語る場所なんですけど
あそこは世界一嘘を交わすところなんですね
あのところほど嘘 裏切りの陰湿あるとこはない
まあそれはね すごい厳しいっていうことはね
もう曖昧じゃない それでこのちょっと今思い出したらええなんですけど
この 好きなものを気に入ってるものがあると
人間っていうのは幸福やというのは一般的に一般論ですよ
例えば金が人が好きでしょ
金があったらこうこうこうね
すごい親しい人々と仲良くすることが人間好きでしょうしね
なんて幸福ですと思うでしょ
いい仕事はある 収入が安定している
人間では幸福やと思う
ブッダは逆言うんですね
好きなものに固まることが人間の苦しみ
悩みの原因になるんだと
結局不幸やってことなんです
あんたがいっぱい金儲けて
本当に福屋が安だな いい家作ってとんでもない不幸な奴だなというような話なんですよ
これがわからないんですよ
この意味は それでみんなこんなことをお釈迦様が言うはずがね
あれほど理屈っぽいことばっかり喋ってるんだからとか
何かちょっと間違っちゃんじゃないかと
いろいろ噂になったんです
それで噂はお釈迦様のところに今の現代人とは違って
やっぱりちゃんと言うんですよ
そこである人に まあお釈迦様の弟子で
サイケの方なんですけど
あのもう一応修行して瞑想してもう悟りを開いている
で まだサイキ この人のブッダがおっしゃったんだから
これがその通りでしょうと
あの仏教とは立場二つあるんだからね
その通りなんですけど
俺にはわからないんだというのは
それでお釈迦様の前でその話になったんです
それで他の人々は やっぱりそれがちょっと
いくらなんでも いくらブッダの言葉であろうとも
もうこれはちょっとおかしいと
みんな仏教徒わけじゃないんだからね
いろいろ異論立てるんですよ
そうするとこの最上の信者さんがこう言うんですよ
人が何を批判しても 私は釈尊もおっしゃったことがその通りで
釈尊も言うんだから おっしゃるんだから
それはその通り事実やと思います
言うとみんなその人から
あんたなんか迷信盲信でしょ
信仰って言ったってそんな
出てこの人をものすごく威張ってこう言うんです
あのね この世界にいる人類がみんな一つの立場に立って
これが間違ってると言っても
私一人だけでもブッダの言葉は正しいという立場を取る
だからお釈迦様はそのポイントを説明する前に
あんた方に見えますかと
仏教は真理知ってる人の強さは
だから世界中みんな言ってるんだからで正しいわけじゃないんです
正しいことはブッダに語られたもののみになるんです
理由は科学者だからね
生命の 全て発見しちゃったんだから
残るなく残りなく 知れ尽くしちゃったんだから
悔しくなってもしょうがないんです
続いています 道徳を守るか守られるかは個人の問題です
命令してないんだからね
それは個人の問題です
ブッダは心に貪瞋痴がある限り
反戦にも反戦には守れないと知っている
仏陀はもう道徳を厳しく言うんだけど
人間にはこれ反戦には守れないんだよということを知ってますよ
だって人間には貪瞋痴があるんだから
貪瞋痴は道徳を犯す原因でしょう
道徳を犯す原因持ちながら
例えば病菌 細菌を体にいっぱいやりながらありながら
絶対病気になりませんよ
それはちょっとやばいでしょうね
いくら気をつけても発する可能性はある
それぐらいのことをお釈迦様は知っている
人間の弱みを知っている
いくら言っても 人間の嘘をつくなから言ったでもすぐ言ってしまうんだよと
この連中は悪いなのにと
それを知っています そこら辺は優しく対処を教えるんです
完全に道徳を守っていると思う人にも懺悔を推薦する
特に仏弟子たちは必死になって命かけて道徳を守っているんです
これということを思い浮かべない
こういう過ちをしましたとか
思い浮かばなくても懺悔する
もし私が知らず知らず間違いを犯ったならば懺悔する
私は何も悪いことしてないぞということは
仏教徒は絶対言ってはならない言葉なんです
言わない 私は何の悪いこともしてないんですよ
それは言えるのは覚った人だけ
だから人間は弱いっていうことは
まあそれはそれでいい
だからって道徳はいい加減にしましょうってことは絶対認めません
道徳は厳しく守る 守ったってあなたにはね
これは守りくはないんだよ
だから懺悔ぐらいしろというだけじゃないんです
仏教徒の信仰者だからといって
道徳的に優れていると思ってはならない
だから仏教はブッダの道徳を守っているんだから
世界一完全な道徳を守ってますよ
しっかり語られている道徳
だからで他の人々より優れているというわけじゃない
例えばキリスト教と比べると
キリスト教はそんなあまり道徳はないんですね
すごい半端なんですけど
で 人は殺さないんだけど
動物は殺したりするわ
まあごちゃごちゃ だからって仏教徒には
あんた方よりは我々は進んでるんだぞとかね
これは絶対言ってはならない言葉なんです
みんな人間なんです 覚るまでは
ま 貪瞋痴はあるんです
だからみんなお互い様
この道徳の世界では まああんまりもう誰にも威張るっていうことはできない
まあ一般的には まあ人間っていうのは誰でも間違いを起こすものだというふうな立場なんです
それを仏教とは見事に実行しなくちゃいけない
我々は人ならなんで間違い起こす
人にでも間違いを起こしたら怒るでしょ
許してあげない 仏教ではそこやってはいけないこと
許してあげるっていうことはものすごい基本的なんです
それから自分がそれに謝る
別に悪いことしてした覚えがなくても
こそがないんです 私 何も悪いことしてないでしょと言ったことは
もう仏道からもう脱線
仲間もう仲間に入らなくなっちゃう
それで人がもう本当にもう仲間がもうとんでもない悪いことしちゃって
こちらも腹が立ってきて
それで向こうが 謝りに来る
その場合 お前なんかに謝ってあげませんよと言っちゃうと
その人も脱線 謝ったら許してあげなくちゃいけない
厳しいんです そのところ
懺悔も世の中に初めて説かれたのは仏教なんです
楽しいことじゃないんです
完全に守ることに挑戦するのみです
だから仏教徒の仕事は道徳を完全に守ってやろうではないかと
挑戦するだけ はい これで第一章終わりました
権利ということ 次に 誰でも戒めるべき内面ということ
これは心の  こんなディスビーンですね
これは誰にでも必要なんです
社会的な道徳より先に内を見なくちゃ
心の中を見なくちゃいけないんです
はい 心は未熟 未完成 一切の行為は心が引き起こすものです
これは仏教的な考え方です
我々の行為は心が引き起こしているのです
行為の管理も心が行われています
行為が善か悪かは心の状態によるものです
行為自体には善も悪もないんです
手を挙げたことは善でも悪でもないんです
心が決めるんです 人には心を見る
成長させる 育てる 清らかにするなどの概念すらないんです
世の中で仏教以外はもう全然ないんですからね
自分の心を育てましょうという話はないんですよ
地理学勉強しようとかね
ピアノを練習しようとかね
まあコンクールのピアノコンクールに参加して
まあもう優勝しようとか
そんな話でしょう 世の中にあるの
心育てようってことは全然ない
仏教文化には一応あまがりになりますけど
物を財産 権力 好ましい人々などを確保することでのみ幸福が成立すると思う
我々はそう思っているんです
物がいっぱい 財産がいっぱいあると
好きな人々がいっぱいあると
権力があると幸福だと
心ということは考えてないんです
ついでに死後天国に行けば同じ幸福を継続
幸福の継続に期待する
まあ時々死後はなんなら死後でもこんな幸せで仲間と一緒に日本のテレビ見るとこの幽霊の話やら撤回の話出てますけど
みんな言うのはみんな家族は向こうでも仲良く
どんな馬鹿者かと 同じ欲の継続ですね
化け合ってるのは 心という話は全然出てこないんです
はい ブッダは一切の創造者
支配者 管理者は自分自身の心だと説く
邪道を進む心は最大限の不幸を築くこと
正道を進む正道を進む心は最大限の幸福を築くことを説く
仏教では問題は心だということ
だから心が間違った道を歩んじゃうと
もう終わり 人生はもう不幸になっちゃう
心が正しい道を歩もうと決めちゃうと
もう幸福だよ 心の成長
巨大化 清浄を推薦する
だから心は成長させなさいと
巨大化にしなさい 弱々しくダメやと
綺麗にしなさいということを推薦する
心は汚れていること 衰弱していること
混乱していることは 行為が乱れる原因なのです
だから人間が悪いことをしたっていうことは
その人の心が衰弱している
混乱しているということ
人が人を殺しちゃうと
この殺した人が加害者はものすごい精神的に衰弱しているんです
すごい混乱に陥っている
病気です 精神的に はい
それが内面のことです
はい それで ブッダは行為そのものより
行為を引き起こす心の状態に重視するべきなのです
だから行為ってそんな気にしなくていいんですよ
歩き方が正しいかないかとかね
変化ないかとか そんなどうったことないんですよ
言葉正しくないかとかね
ちょっと乱暴な失礼な言葉を使っているではないかとか
そんなのは別に 特に日本の文化っていうのは
もう表表形式形式ばっかりでしょ
ちゃんと度ぐらいもう背筋を曲げて挨拶すればそれでぴったしや
そんなのはどうでもいいんです
背筋を曲げても曲げなくても
問題は心なんです 無知未明がありじゃっていうことは
悪の根本原因です 無知によって欲と怒りも心に現れる
それはまあ一応説明しました
この前の場合は 無知ということはありますね
真理知らないってこと
それから怒りというものが生まれますね
心の中に 基本的には貪瞋痴という 3つの悪を引き
3つは悪を引き起こす原因です
だから基本的に心には貪瞋痴があります
それが悪を引き起こすんですよ
だからヤバいのはこの貪瞋痴なんです
人にこの野郎って言ったっても罪になりませんよ
心に怒りがあると罪なんです
その人はもうすごく好きで可愛いんだから
やったことはすごく立派なことだから
褒める代わりにこの野郎と言ったっても
別に罪でもなんでもないんです
例えば子供が点満点取ってきたら
この野郎点取ってるんだぞとか言ったっても
別にどういったことないでしょう
だから言葉自体どうったことない
行為自体どうったことない
心の状態が問題なんです
そこまで読んで 道徳設定の場合はこの三毒を排除することがポイントなのです
だからすごい科学的な医学的なことなんです
これは心理学的なことなんです
この心にあるこの三毒
この毒を解毒しなくちゃいけないんですよ
そのためにあれこれあれこれと言わなくちゃいけないんです
だから病気になった時と同じなんですよ
高血圧の人に油の油のものや塩やらね
食べるなよと言ったっても
これは失礼でもなんでもないでしょうに
迷惑でも その病気になる原因を排除しなくちゃいけない
しかし 三毒は人間の生きるエネルギーになっているので
賛成してもらうのは容易ではありませんよ
人間どもの生きるエネルギーはもう貪瞋痴なんですよ
それがね 生きていられないと思ってるんです
もういい加減なんですと
貪瞋痴でもう地獄の苦しみを味わってるのに
だから言っても言っても理解はしてくれない
納得はしてくれない が
仏教の道徳は絶対的です
どうしようもないです
だから納得するかしないかっていう指導
という状態になるんです
はい まあ次に行きましょう
十七枚目 貪瞋痴はすべての生命にあるのです
その感情によって引き起こされる行為は
時代 信仰 知識 性別などに関係なく
悪行為になるのです あ
これは三毒は普遍的ということなんです
これ なんでそんなことは言うのかというと
よくいますよ 世の中で
道徳っていうのはこの時代によって変わりますよとかね
でいて仏教を馬鹿にしてるんです
自分のこと馬鹿にしなくてもいいんだけど
で なんででしょうかと
だって戦争のした時は我々は別な考え方でいて
戦争に負けたらもう 日にちにしてまた変わったんでしょうとか価値観が
それで仏教関係ないでしょうに
そんないい加減なことを言って仏教の道徳をけなしてやろうと
悲しみなら で 私に言うのはあなた方は前もおかしかったし
頭が狂っていたし 戦争に負けてからも頭狂ったまんまやと
ただ狂い方変わっただけや
しか言えないでしょう
だから世の中で時代によって価値観変わると
昔ありましたからね まあ女性と男性は日本のは一緒に歩いたあかんとかね
日本はどうか分かりませんだけど
今はもう一緒に歩くんじゃなくて
やりたいこと全部道路でやったりもするし
だからもう道徳変わるんだそうとか
そんなことを言ったもんじゃないんでしょうに
それは人間のやりやることであって
仏教はそうじゃなくて科学的に言ってるんで
心には貪瞋痴がある 貪瞋痴が引き起こす行為は全部不道徳であると
それに性別も関係ない
時代も関係ない だってどんな時代でも人間に貪瞋痴があるんだから
種族も関係ない どんな生命かということも
犬であるか虎であるか関係ないんです
神であるかも関係ないんです
道徳はみんなに当てはまる
人間に限らず 一切の生命に対してもこの法則なのです
人はモラル道徳を考えるより先に
この内面の問題を重視するべきものです
道徳には内面があるんだよ
根元があるんだよ 心という
そこが分かればね そんなに難しい問題ではないんです
道徳って 大体そこら辺の人は思うでしょう
これで第二章は終わります
えーと 第三章 まあ道徳的な行動でね
こういうのは普遍面ありまして
そうでない面もありますということ
貪瞋痴を戒める目的でブッダに語られた道徳は普遍です
変えることはできません
変えること 訂正することはこと
否定することは不可能です
真面目にはできません
まあいい加減は否定するかもしれませんだけど
たとえ他宗教の方にさえもこれは違うと論理的に
実証的に 客観的に見るならば不可能であると釈尊が説く
釈尊がそう言っているんです
神々であろうと 梵天であろうか
人間であろうと バラモンであろうか
他の宗教の人であろうか
知識人であろうか 言ったことは違いますよと言えません
教典ものすごいたくさんあります
あの引用するのはすごく難しいというかね
面倒くさいしね もう取り上げてないんですけど
もう道徳っていうのは誰にも変えられないんだよという態度でいろんな人と対話するんですよ
お釈迦様は 中部経典たくさんそういう教典があります
すごい論理的ですけど
人の主観で好き勝手に普遍的な心の法則を変えることができません
心はある法則で流れてるんで
それを変えられません
法則だから この例えば地球は自転するっていうことは法則でしょうね
私が嫌だからって変えられますかね
変えられませんよ だから心が無知で貪瞋痴で機能しているということは
法則なんです 今の場合
だから幸福になりたければ
貪瞋痴を完全に残りなく取り除くしかないんです
それが幸福の道 それを釈迦様おっしゃってます
はい それで普遍的な道徳
項目 絶対誰にも変えることのできない道徳の項目は一応 10種類あります
10種類にまとめているだけ
リストはいくつもあります
これは十善十悪と知られている項目です
心の内面を重視して説かれている他の普遍的な項目も
他の道徳項目もあるが
この 10 は伝統的に確定されています
あまりもお釈迦様も回数多いんだから
どんどんどんどん他のリストよりも
確定している この本 サーリプッタ経
こちらは道徳項目はたくさんあります
どれぐらい？だって 44 あります
40 こちらで 44 もありますけど
この経典 1箇所しか出てこないんで 44 のリストは
他の経典また数字が変わるんです
いろいろまあそれぞれ説明する立場によって
しかしこの 10項目はもうものすごいたくさん出てきます
特に一般の人々と喋る場合は 10項目出ます
これはまあブッダの弟子たちにということで
ものすごい厳しく言ってるだけのことです
仏教の場合は初期仏教に関わらず
大乗仏教も十善十悪を認めるのです
これ否定できません みんな守ってないんだけど
で 大乗では菩薩戒と言っているようです
その菩薩戒って言葉使っただけの人を馬鹿にしてやるぞという卑しい気持ちで
菩薩戒でもなんでもないんですよ
もう普遍的な道徳であって
これは犬でも猫でも守らなきゃあかんことですよ
そいつらわからないだけの話で
それで 浄土の連中じゃあ我々は菩薩戒守っているそうでいて
ただ我々守るべき戒律を否定することに言い訳するのです
だから十善十悪は戒律に入りません
戒律じゃないんです ものすごい間違いなんです
戒律と道徳の差はまたそれから説明します
戒律というのは約束事
ブッダとの だからそれはもう大きくなったり小さくなったり
自分が約束はそこら約束もしますか
たくさん約束するか それはそれでいいんでしょうよ
しかし 普遍的な道徳 法則はもう誰にも変えることができない
だから仏教の立場というのは
たとえキリスト教であろうとも
イスラム教であろうとも
無宗教であろうとも 犬で猫であろうとも
この十善十悪はもうただ
の法則でやっちゃうとそれなりの結果が出てくる
はい 次 それでこの十善十悪のリスト
悪の悪のリストだけ紹介します
善のリストはそれの反対項目です
で これ体の行為 一番目は殺生
二番目は止ない 何でしたっけ？ 中盗です
中盗 これにはすごい時間がかかったんですよ
漢字を探すために 三十分ぐらいかかっちゃった
で 三番目は邪淫 それ体でやること
これが他宗教に見ると正しいと言えますか？どんな宗教の人だって否定できませんよ
では 宗教を信仰していない人は？無宗教の人に否定できる？できませんよ
私は宗教を持ってないんだけど
それは勝手ですけど でもこの三つの道徳否定できますかね？できません
これ体の行為 はい 次 それは言葉の行為
離間ごうとしかなんかね
容赦すというまあ噂話ですね
人を仲間割れるような言葉喋る
仲が割れてしまう お互いに喧嘩になるような
そんなのは宗教があってもなくても汚いやろうのやり方でしょうに
宗教と関係ないんです
で 七番目は無駄話 四番目は嘘
五はそわく  そわく  これまた時間かかっちゃったんですよ
もう時間なくなったの
そういうこの漢字を一つ探すためなんです
別にこういう作るのにそんな時間かかりません
言葉の行為 その四つにしても
別に宗教と関係ないでしょう
これがダメやと言えますかね
正気の人だったら 言えないでしょ
だからこの項目はもう絶対的なんです
いくらの場合でも変えることできない
どれほど頑張っても はい
次 で いの 心の行為 異常な欲
アビッチャという それから異常な怒り
マーパ で 十番目は邪見
で これが精神的な問題です
精神的に頭がおかしいということ
もう簡単に言えば でも頭がおかしいのはいいんですかね
いいわけないでしょう
宗教と関係ないんです
八と九は精神が正常を失った場合です
十は仏教以外のものは邪見という意味ではなくて
これは宗教的な意味じゃないんですよ
仏教だけが正見で 他の教えは邪見だという排他的な教えじゃないんです
真理を知らないがゆえにあらゆる妄想概念を知識として抱くことです
真理を知らないんだから
例えば無常という真理あるでしょう
真理である無常 苦 因縁法則を知らないことにより
他の概念を持つ だから真理知らないというぐらいのことです
世の中はそうでしょうね
昔は何も知らなかったんだから
あらゆる嘘ばっかり信じ込んでいて
どんどん科学が発展していろんなものを発見して発見していくと
もうそんなのは崩れて崩れていく
今もまだまだ心のことを発見していないし
命って何なのかわかってないんだから
そこら辺でまだ宗教の人々はえらいことを言ってるんです
だから一切は無常であると
苦であると 全て因縁によって成り立つ現象であるということが事実なんです
それが発見するまでの概念は全部邪見なんです
だから地球が丸いと知ったら知らなかった時は
これ邪見でしょ 丸いと分かっているんだったら邪見を捨てちゃうんです
だからこの心の問題ですね
八九十は はい あんまり説明する暇がないので進みます
十善は十悪の反対ですが
ただ何もしないという意味ではありません
殺生しないという風に書いてます
だから何もしないという意味じゃないんです
嘘をつかないと言えば何もしなきゃいいでしょう
そういう意味ではないんです
えーと 貪瞋痴という悪を抑えつつ壊しつつ心を向上させることです
例えば私は嘘をつくということは行為なんですね
ポジティブ的な 能動的な行為なんです
嘘言わないって黙ってればいいでしょ
簡単なことじゃないです
あれは嘘をつくよりも働かないと
仕事をしないと精神的に
大変な仕事なんです それで嘘言わない
殺生しないということになってくると
貪瞋痴を抑えなくちゃいけない
嘘をついたい気持ちを抑えなくちゃいけないんです
殺したい気持ち 怒りを抑えなくちゃいけないんですよ
結構仕事なんです だからこの善行をやるということは
内面を管理することなんです
心 あの外ではそんなに見えませんよ
巡巡回っている人は別に何も外では何も見えません
内面ではものすごい仕事です
悪にはリミットがあるが
善には制限がありません
悪っていうのは どこまで人が悪に陥るかということは決まってます
無限に悪に陥ることは不可能です
悪の最低限はあります
底っていうのは こんなみんな知らないんですよ
法のおすし知らないんだから
悪っていうのは心を汚れることでしょう
まあここまでやというね
リミットがあるんです
悪を犯すと心がどんどん小さく縮んじゃうんです
ここまでやというリミットがあるんです
心が弱くなるんですよ
しかし ここまでという弱みのリミットがあるんです
それ以上弱みになっちゃうと法則違反なんです
だって生命維持しているんだから
生命維持するためには心は必要
例えば脳細胞ないミミズにいたっても心があるんですよ
すごい弱い 生命ですからね
アメーバにもあります
脳細胞ニューロン 1個もないでしょ
しかし 心があります しかしすごい弱い
だからこの弱みにも最小のリミットっていうのはあるんです
しかし 逆はそうじゃないんです
広げてみようと思ったらもうかなり広げられます
強化しようと思っちゃえば
善の方は結構あります
それも仏教的仏教の心理学でそうなっています
世界は分かりません 世界はそこまで知っているはずもないのです
心の成長は頂点に達した
達したら心が解脱するので
善悪の次元を乗り越えるのです
心は成長して頂点に達しちゃうと
心は解脱するという輪廻転生を乗り越えてしまうんです
それからもう人間には想像できないというブッダの悟りの境地
それについて語るなよと
疑ってわかるわけないんだよと言いたいところです
だからまあかなり成長はできます
堕落はもうリミットがあります
はい 十悪 十善は絶対的な不道徳と道徳です
それは絶対的です 時代と状況と関係ない
心の普遍的な法則を見極めた
知り尽くした上で説かれているのです
誰にも変えることはできません
認めとも 認めなくても事実です
他のモラリストも似ている道徳を語ってはいるが
真理を知り尽くして言っているのではなく
他の行為は悪行為は自分に迷惑という具体的な経験から考えたものです
これ説明しました 我々も人に嘘をつくなというのは
自分に嘘をついたらもう嫌だからなんです
だから世の中にある道徳はそういう道徳
そのレベルの道徳なんです
自分では嘘ついたいんです
自分に嘘をつくのは嫌なんです
だから言うんです 嘘をつくな
だから他の世の中のモラリストも嘘をつくなとか
殺傷するなかれ 噂を言うなかれと言ってますよ
でも彼らの言い方とブッダの言い方はものすごい違う
ブッダはこの法則を発見して知り尽くして言ってるんだよって
俺が嫌だからっていう状態で言ってるわけじゃないんです
はい それでBの下辺ですね
我々に変えることもできる道徳もあります
人に訂正変更できる道徳もあるのです
変化可能な道徳 不道徳も結局は基本道徳に基づくものです
基本道徳十ありまして
そこに基づいてはいます
が 人間に変えることはできます
人は道徳の変化が可能な側面と変化不可能な側面の区別を明確に知らないから
世界の道徳は曖昧なものになっている
この区別はみんな知らない
変えることできる道徳
変えられない道徳という二つあるんだよ
勝手に変えられると思ってるんで
それは誰でも道徳守りたくないんだから言ってる泣き声ですよ
それ そういうこと 十悪をやめるために
十善を行うために 人間はいろいろな決まり
約束 規則などを作らなくてはならない
よく覚えておいてください
我々は十悪を 例えば殺生してはいけないということがありますね
だから殺生しないためにいろいろ約束事を作るんです
それ約束事だから変えたり変えなかったりすることはできます
例えば日本の人々は人を殺したくないと思って自衛隊に入ることは拒否すると
それはできます これは時代
社会 民族 文化などによって変わるものです
この人間の約束事は 時代
社会 文化によって変わるんですよ
また 変えるべきものなのです
人間の約束事だからね
それをもう変えるべきなんですね
時代によって 憲法を守りつつ国会が法律を作ることと同じです
だから仏教の道徳憲法は十善十悪なんです
これが絶対的 それ守りつつ
その上に人間が自分の好き勝手な道徳を作る
それで日本の政府には憲法というものがあるんです
それは絶対的で守らなくちゃいけない
それを守りながら 我々にもうちょっと税金払ってくれとかね
消費税をもっと上げて
上げてやろうとかね いろいろ法律作るんですよ
どんな法律作っても基本的に憲法に逆らってはならない
もし憲法に逆らったら
その時点で法律は無効なんです
自分の国ではもう今昨日から大変ですけど
面白いんです 一般人ももう法律もう最高裁判所に訴えるんです
自分の権利が破られちゃったとか
たとえ国会で何か決めても一般人にできますよ
もし憲法に違反しているならば
憲法で守られてる私の権利はこれで破れますよ
まあ難しいんだけど 時々もうある原住民の人の人がね
警察にちょっといじめられたっていうことで
バカにされたからかって
最高裁にかけたんです
生活は森の中で生活してますよ
まだまだ彼らはもう文化にもあまり入りたくないんですよ
ほんの少ないんですけど
人数 数は でも一人の人がもう堂々と
あれ見てるとすごく楽しかったんですよ
みんなもう頑張ってるんだと
で なぜかっていうと この自分の訴えは
警察は自分の喋ってる言葉で書きなさいと言ったら
警察できませんと ほんのちょっとシンハラ語と混じってる単語なら誰でもわかります
あれって別に勉強しなくたってたくさん単語あるわけでもないし
それで自分の民族のプライドを持って
警察は自分に対して訴えるんだったら
私の言い分は自分の単語言葉で書きなさいと言ったら
それとはこいつはただの原住民でしょっていうことで
もうそういうなんか差別感でね
シンハラ語で言わなきゃお前対応してやるぞと言って
一日入れちゃった 一日以上はできませんだからね
それに最高裁判所 私の権利をかけた
ただ裁判で言うんです
私はシンハラ語を知ってますよと
だって裁判でシンハラ語でなきゃもう喋れませんからね
知ってるんだからといって私の権利があるんだと
自分の言葉に対する権利がある
どうなったかはわかりませんけどもね
まあおそらく弁護士さんはね
タダで無料で協力するとは思いますけど
だからただ余計な話で言ったのは
このたとえ国会があるとしたっても
憲法変えることできません
法律は憲法を守りつつ作るものなんです
それで仏教道徳の場合は
十善十悪が絶対的な憲法で
それを守りつつ 我々にはそれなりの決まり事を作れます
法律作ったり無効にしたりするが
憲法を守る必要はない
はい 次に行きます ブッダの道徳は憲法よりも厳しいんです
これは法則ですからね
普遍的な心の法則に合わせたものなので 3
分の2の合意も万場一致の一致合意合意も通じない
通じないんです これは地球は自転するんだぞということと同じだから
人類は万場一致で自転しないぞと言ったって意味がないでしょうに
だから憲法のたとえあまり良くないたって
憲法も議員の方々の 3分の2と日本語わかりませんだけど
国民のレファレンダムというものがありますね
国民投票でしたね それで 50%以上取っちゃえばもう変えられます
だから憲法も変えられますが
ブッダの道徳憲法は誰にもブッダにさえも教えたブッダにさえも変えられ
ことはできません 別に仏教がわざわざ作ったわけじゃないんだから
人は地球上でいろいろ決まりを作っても
昼と夜は存在しないと定めることはできません
夜も灯りを照らして仕事をするのはそれは勝手ですけどね
夜はないことにすることはできません
変化可能な道徳も 重善重悪項目を減収した上で設定する
設定するものです はい
変化可能 それで戒律ということになります
この変化可能な道徳に戒律というわけです
大乗仏教はまあまあそれを潰れてるんだから
もう戒律なきゃあかんだから
もう重善重悪に戒律って言わんと
変化可能な規則はシーラ戒律と言います
しかし 戒律もブッダが設定したならば
人間にも神々にもそれを変えられません
本当は戒律は変えられるんですよ
あの 変化可能です あの重善重悪の上で作った法律だから
変えられますけど 戒律作ったのはブッダだったらもう手を入れません
なぜならば真理で作ってるんだから
それにチャレンジできないんです
ブッダは戒律項目を設定することは好まなかったのですが
社会状況変わるたびに定めざるを得なかったのです
最初は戒律なかったんです
約束事なんか重善重悪で十分でした
でも人間っていうのはごちゃごちゃ悪いことしちゃうんだから
坊さんたちとかね それでお釈迦様は一つ一つ戒律を定めたんです
したがって 戒律は徐々に増えたものです
大事だと思えない小さな戒律変える自由も仏子弟子にあります
だからブッダの弟子たちに出家にも戒律を変える自由はあります
大事じゃないと思いならば
で あの お釈迦様は一応あの戒律変えてもいいよ
まあ言ってはありました
それであの戒律の中で五戒は有名です
すべての人間が信仰に関わらず守った方が良いという立場をとっているのです
五戒は一番基本的でお釈迦様が定めたもので
別に世の中であったんです
それは 誰でも守った方がいいと
宗教には関係ないんだ
その五戒は殺生しないこと
盗む盗みはしないこと
邪淫はしないこと 嘘をつかないこと
酒麻薬使用しないということですね
だから以上いくらでも作れますよ
これもブッダに決めちゃったんだから
我々には文句の権利ない
守るしかないんです 守れないん守れないけど
これは自分の弱みと認めることで
それは別な話です サイケ仏教とは都合により八戒
十戒 十戒なども時々守りますよ
だから仏教の場合はもう五戒はもうずっと一生守らなくちゃいけない
時々もうちょっとたくさん守りましょうと言って
満月の日とかね 新月とか八回
一日中守ったりする でも毎日八戒は守れません
だから毎日は五戒にする
満月ぐらいになってくると
では八回も八回やりましょう
日つけて あるいは十回やりましょうと
戒律はもう減ったり増えたりします
また 出家戒 出家戒 複数にあります
出家戒律はもう億単位なんです
十いくわけじゃないんです
十億ぐらいあるんだと思います
まあ億以上なんです 項目ごとに数えると
それらは全ての生命は必ず守るべきと言えるものではありません
例えば出家には億単位の戒律はあっても
それは出家だけ守るんであって
他の人に関係ない 満月の日は仏教徒が十戒守っている
それは仏教徒の仕事であって
キリスト教の人は心配する必要はないんです
守らなかったんだから地獄に落ちるわけでも
罪を犯しているわけでもないんです
しかし 五戒ぐらいは犯しちゃうと罪を犯す
それはあの重善重悪から作っているから
心を清らかにする過程をスピードアップするためのものです
早く悟りたいと思う人はたくさん戒律を約することを守るんです
それだけのこと はい 条件付きで変える自由はあるが
ブッダに説かれた戒律は完璧な項目なので
仏弟子は手を加えようとしません
お釈迦様ももう毎日毎日戒律足して足して足してもう今五冊ですよ
三蔵経ありますね  三蔵経の3分の1ですよ
律宗経っていうのは 全部戒律です
ものすごい でもお釈迦様はそれも約束事だから
まあ自由に変えてくださいよ
時代によって変えてくださいよと自由を与えています
しかし 我々仏教徒はとんでもない
これはお釈迦様自身で述べたものだから
これはもうどうにもならんと
だって 小学者が真理知り尽くして言ってるんだから
我々もうとんでもない凡夫はね
そんなもう汚すものじゃないよってことで
ものすごい真剣に手加えようとはしない
大乗仏教はこの点で見事に失敗してしまったのです
余計なことをやって 未だに認めていない
自分たちが失敗しちゃった
別に大乗仏教戒律をやめましょうと思ったことは
ブッダに違反したわけじゃないんですよ
だって仏様もその自由を与えたんだから
でも彼らがブッダを侮辱しちゃったんです
その時点で仏教から脱線
なぜお釈迦様決めたんだから守るのが当然でしょうに
仏教徒であるなら 他宗教だったら守る必要はないんですけど
変えてもいいよと言っても
変えるわけにはいきませんよ
変えたところで滑って擦れてしまうからです
結果として 人間には仏教は嫌なものになってしまう
仏教はみんな揃って喜んで行うべき
すごい知識的な理性に満たしている
ものすごい抜群な宗教なんですよ
これはヨーロッパ人の前で惨めにはなりませんよ
仏教とは とんでもなくなっちゃう
でも それ仏教は未だにヨーロッパ人であろうが何人であろうが
一切惨めじゃないんです
すごい堂々と語れるし
対話できる 例えば日本の社会からもう何もなくてもなくなっちゃって
もう混乱状態に陥ったのは別に誰も信じてくれないし
すごくおかしくなっちゃったんです
だからそれはもうあれ失敗
大失敗 意図的に変えなくても
ある社会状況に合わせた prets はその状況が変わると自動的に関係がなくなる
だから意図 戒律変えなくてもいいんですよ
何億あっても これ社会状況に合わせてお釈迦様が教えたものだから
社会状況変わるとあの戒律項目は関係ない
一つ例を出しました 例えば比丘はこれメスですね
メスの動物引く車に乗ってはならないんで戒律です
今関係ないでしょう 今メスもオスも車引いてないんだから
でしょ もし私たちは偉そうにこんな戒律を削除しましょうと思っちゃうと全て壊れるんです
だから今誰も気にしない
その戒律を だから何であんなバカなことをやったのか
あの無知な方々 テーラワーダと聖教奉教の大乗仏教がすごい違うところは多分それだけなんです
別に牛やら馬 女人やら何やらね
そんなのはもう別にそんなにお互いに反対してるわけじゃないんですよ
やってはいけないことを引いてはいけない
あれ引いちゃったんです
全部壊れちゃったんです
はい 社会の元々 社会も時と場合に合わせて道徳項目を作るのです
社会人も道徳作りますよ
親も作るしね おじいさんも作るし
しょうがないんです 法律もその一部なんですよ
法律もよくよく見れば道徳のようなもんなんです
その社会で生活する人々は守らなくてはならないのです
しかし これらの道徳も法律も変化可能なものです
それは変化可能です また
徐々に改良しなくてはならないのです
変化可能だけじゃなくて
ずっと昔から守っているんだからといって
いやらしい意味のない道徳守る必要ないんですよ
社会が決めたものだから
文化だから  300年もやっていたんだからとか
日本では女性の天皇がいなかったんだからとか
どうでもいいんで そんなことは
何の意味もない そういうバカなことを厳守するのはもう本当に馬鹿らしいんです
だから社会道徳っていうのは
もうすきすき過ぎすといい方向
いい方向へ変えて変えていかなくちゃいけないんです
はい 社会の決まりは宗教的なものではないので
守ってもらうために罰というものも決まります
だから仏教と違うところは
嘘を言ったらこれぐらい罰だよと法律で決めちゃうんですね
人を殺したらこれこれやとかね
それは社会道徳には宗教的なものじゃないんだから
もう肉体的に何か罰を与えないと守ってくれないんですね
ブッダのモラルの場合は自浄自業自得という論理なんです
誰に迷惑はあります 自分が行った行為の結果
自分が得るんです だからオートなんです
罰は 自業自得っていうのはそういう意味なんです
例えば 人は人を殺した
それで裁判で死刑に決める
しかし 誰かがあのスイッチを入れなくちゃいけないでしょ
なんでその人は人を殺さなくちゃいけないんですかね
とんでもないことなんです
アメリカで薬注射して人を殺しますけど
それでもあれは機械でオートで毒は体に入りますけど
だからってこれは人がちゃんと時間を見て
実行する 1 秒でスイッチ入れなくちゃいけないんですよ
これとんでもないことなんです
その人殺人とか法律では殺人じゃないんだけど
仏教から見れば命を奪っちゃったんですよ
その人は悪人ではないか
それもその人を知ったことじゃないでしょう
自業自得だから 死刑にしてもしなくても
その人は逃げられません
自分がするから心にあるんだから
だからこの罰を与えるっていう
例えば神様が最後に全ての生命を処分するということで
とんでもなく恐ろしい話なんですよ
人殺しは 仏教ではそういう神様
悪魔様も山も誰もいらん
オートで起こります これは法則です
仏教とは社会の道徳法律を厳守するが
ブッダの道徳を重視する
仏教徒の立場は 社会の法律もすごい大事に守る
ごまかしもしない しかし
それよりもブッダのあの十項目はもっと大事です
ブッダの法に逆らう社会の決まりに反対するが
いまだに社会的な問題を犯してはいけない
もし政府が戒律 法律決める
その法律は仏教には反対している
そうすると仏教徒は守りません
いくら法律であれ 徹底的に反対する
そうすると社会問題が起こるでしょ
面白いことにいまだに起きてないんです
それはもう完全たる悟った人の教えを守っているんだから
微かな問題も起こりませんということはないです
例えばイスラム教徒ね
例えばフランスでね あのあれ
何といいますか 頭を隠す
あれね やめてくださいと
宗教的なシンボルをフランス人は宣言で言ってるんですよ
イスラム人はすごくもう変な目で見られてるし
わざわざ私はイスラム教だと言っちゃうとみんな逃げるんだから
怖くて だったらもうそういう宗教シンボルを置いておいた方が
みんな何宗教かわからない方がいいという
まあすごい立派な考え方なんですけど
このイスラム連中はもう頑固と反対するんですね
それはもう別にコーランにそんなこと書いてることがわかりませんけれどもね
どうでもいいことなんです
女性はもう男にはもう顔を見せてはいけない
髪の毛を見せてはいけない
手も見せ 手もここら辺だけ以外は見せてはいけないという
そんなことイスラム人が女の体一部見たところで頭が狂うかもしれませんけれど
この世の中にはもう飽きちゃってね
見ても面白いことも何もないんですよ
だって体丸出しで出るこの世の中で
イスラムの国ほど犯罪性犯罪起こし起きてますかね？起きてないでしょう
あの最近のあの日本でも何て言ったっけ
あの Burn Alive という
あの  生きながら  生きながら焼かれた女性の話を書いた本があります
で 日本訳もあるということで
私も読みましたけど 英文で
悲しいんですよ あの決してイケ men 嫌いにしてる本じゃないんですよ
本当にすごい NGO のことをやるためにね
こういう風に女性をね
まあ大変差別されているんだ
だからそれ宗教と関係なくこれはやめましょうということね
どうせ好きな男と一緒にいたんだからと言って
もう灯油かけてガソリンかけて火をつけて
心底ないんですよ 殺しましょうと決めるのは親なんですよ
自分の子どもに それにそういう仏教も同じですよ
ブッダの法は絶対的で
国の法律なんかもう全然相手にしないが
遵守しなさいとブッダは教えてますよ
教えてますけど それもブッダの法律に合う時なんです
合わないと反対しますが
いまだにそうし問題を見てないです
はい イギリス人の時は自分の国では植民地の時はね
結構トラブっちゃったんですけど
どうトラブったってイギリスが負けることでは
これでまあ 第三章があって
第章あと読みだしたら止まらない
時間なかったら置いといてやります
第章では例外という問題を考えます
例外の危機 例外立てる反面
社会との調和というモラル例外の英語で例外というわけです
書冊ぐらいと思ってもちょっと長いんですね
はい 例外の危機 仏弟子は最初に見つけたものです
例外は危機である 釈尊にすごい小さな戒律を変えても良いと遺言なさったのです
ブッダかあのブッダか戒律はやめてやめてもよろしいと
はっきりおっしゃったんですよ
アニジャナームビクエママッチェーヌクッダカーヌクッダカーニクッダカーニシッカーパダーニサムーハネイユンっていうはっきり教えたんです
項目だから変えるものは変えられますよと
小さい小さなというサイズはどのように決めるものかわかりません
これが小さな戒律よと
どうやって決めるんですかね
やりだすとすべてのムラッラ個人の好みで破壊してしまうんですよ
あ これが小さいんだから取り消しましょう
次に残ったあ じゃあこれが小さい取り消しましょうと
残ったじゃあこれ小さいんだから取り消しましょうと
こういうことになるでしょうに
だからできないんですよ
それは例外の危機なんですよ
したがって 仏教徒は守らなくても戒律は変えません
仏教徒は別に戒律守ってる立派な信者じゃないんですよ
だけど 戒律変えようとは思わないんです
はい エブリールールハスイツエクセプションズの英語の言葉言葉なんですね
という言葉もあります
これは日本訳になってくるとどうなりますか
例外のない規則はない
それはありません 規則はいつでも例外はあるんだよと
道徳 十善 十悪には例外はありませんが
当然戒律にはあります
仏教も同じですよ 十善十悪には例外はありません
しかし戒律には例外があります
しかし 例外を作ると戒律そのものが弱くなる
不安定になるんです 例外があるというのはちょっと不安定なんです
人はこの隙間から逃げようとするのです
いつでも法律では抜け道あるでしょ
これ例外のせいなんですよ
みんなそれで戒律守ることじゃなくて
抜け道ばっかり探すんです
なんで仏教の律宗というのはすごい膨大な号冊になっているわけで
その例外の問題なんです
抜け道は入れてないんです
例外があるって すごい厳しいんです
そこはインドで 嚴密に計算しています
はい 人を殺すのは当然法律かもしれませんが
道徳ではありません 人を殺すのは当然の法律ですけど
あれは道徳じゃない 動物を除くので例外は大きすぎです
殺してはならない しかし人のみです
殺してはならない しかし動物以外というと
例外はあまりに膨大 そうするとそれは道徳じゃないんです
ただの人間が勝手に作った法律です
だから法律の中でも人を殺してもいいということになっている
同じ法律の中 悪人なら殺してよいとすると
悪人の定義は勝手にできるので好き勝手に殺せる
社会では悪人なら殺してもいいってことになってるでしょ
それで人間まあまあ法律ある国ではね
もう殺人する人ぐらいですけど
悪人にするのはまあそれも厳しい法律で裁判を行ってから
もうあんたは有罪だと決めるんですが
世界みんなそうじゃないでしょう
いろんな文化でもああいう
あのパキスタン それから超党
パレスチナ それから南アメリカ
どこかのこの国ではもう家畜の肝に守らなかったら子供を親が殺すんです
だから平気でやっちゃうんです
だから悪人なら殺すなかれという例外を置いちゃうと
もう管理できなくなっちゃう
人が好き勝手に お前は悪人だぞと決めちゃいます
例えばキリスト教は正当の宗教と決めちゃうと
キリスト教でない人は悪人になっちゃう
殺してもいいということになりたい
イスラム教こそが正当やと思っちゃうと
それ以外はみんな だから間違いない
そういうとんでもない例外を作ってはいけないんですよ
法廷も軍人も人を殺すが
その組織は人の決まりに従うが
心の普遍的な法則に逆らっている
例えば軍人は人を殺す
殺人じゃありません 法廷も人を殺す
もうね 殺人者をね 殺すんだけど
法廷は殺人罪じゃないでしょ
しかし 仏教ではダメです
命には生きる権利があるんですよ
だからそれ奪ってはならないんです
軍人でも人を殺したらもう殺人になります
仏教では そこで人を殺した人は裁判で処刑するでしょ
それはその人が人の命を奪ったんだから
自分に生きる権利がなくなってるんです
だから裁判で殺されるんですけど
そちらに関わってる人が余計な罪に汚染される
ものすごいややこしいんですよ
しかし 仏教の自業自得論でいけば
人を殺しちゃうと一回だけじゃないんですよ
数えられない回数自分が殺されるんです
それで地獄に落ちたら
もう何億年も苦しいものです
地獄からいきなり人間界には行けないんです
だってもうものすごい長い間
あの苦しみの次元で心が回転してたんだから
地獄から死ぬ時でもほとんどを嘆いてまた地獄
だから知ってる人はもう自分を殺しても殺されても人は
ものすごい怖くなる それで世の中の可哀想なところっていうのは
例えば過去世で人を殺した人が今世に誰かに殺されちゃう
で 殺した人が新しい罪を犯しちゃって
その人は殺す殺された
で そこで刺された人々も多かれ少なかれ人殺しに参加する
無茶なんですよ この生命の法則っていうのは
心の法則っていうのはものすごい怖いもんなんです
それがその通りに起こる
僕大変なことやって これは遊びじゃないよとおっしゃったのはブッダだけなんです
喜んでる場合じゃないよ
ものすごい危険な世界です
存在なんです もう関係なく染め上げられますからね
[終始背景音楽]例えば人がもう余計なインターネット見たり
コンピューターゲームやったりして
もう精神的にちょっとおかしくなる
仕事うまくいかなくなったとかでおかしくなる
それ自体は罪なんですよ
頭が混乱した自体に 心の罪だから
それでその人はもうイライラして誰でもいいんだから見て殺しちゃう
ちょうどその時誰かが誰かを見つかるでしょ
被害者が 被害者が自分の過去の罪でちょうどうまい具合にそちらに噛み合うんです
で やられちゃう それで被害者は自分の罪
過去の罪で殺されますけど
こいつはどうですか 新しい殺人罪を犯していて
またこの馬鹿も何億回も地獄に落ちたり
殺されたりせなきゃいけない
それで殺された人が 殺された被害者が
皆様は腹が立つかもしれませんけど
私はそれは被害者の過去の業の結果だと堂々と言うんです
何も罪のない子供が殺されたと
神戸で学校にいて 誰かが何人か子供殺したでしょう
それで我々から見れば可愛い子供たち殺すとは何たることかと思う気持ちは私も分かりますよ
私の子供は好きでしょうし
殺されたらすごく腹が立つでしょうし
殺されるなと思ったら
まあもう何とかしてやめやめることもするし
しかし だからといって殺された子供たちも
これ過去の業なんですよ
それにその子供たちは一回殺されたから罪が終わったかというと
これはわからない また何回同じことを繰り返す羽目になるかわからない
殺した人も あの その宅間という人が死刑にしましたけど
もうすごい楽になりますと
早くやってくださいと本人から頼んだみたいですね
早く実行してくださいと
本人がえらい勘違いしてるんです
それで日本の法律で自分が死刑にしたら
あ これで楽だと 楽わけじゃない
それから地獄に落ちるんだから
うちの子 いややっぱりもう死刑延ばした方が良かったなと思うでしょうね
だからもう罪っていうのはそうやってウイルスみたいに増える
それで宅間がもうやがてやがてもうこの宇宙が破壊されて
またもう新しい宇宙ができたところで
人間になったりするでしょ
殺されなくちゃならないんですよ
本人が その恨み持ってるんだから
そうしちゃうと誰かが殺すでしょ
そいつはかわいそうに
というわけで 罪っていうのはかなり複雑なものなんです
各政府は気のままに死刑を決めたり止めたりもする
だからもう人間の法律はそんなもんで
もう死刑決めたり決めなかったり
自分の国も最近裁判官を殺しちゃって
すぐ政府はもうたじまで死刑決めましょう
私はあんまりそういうのはもう厳しい法律じゃないとダメやとなんとかと
そういう目には目とやり方はあんまり仏教的ではないと
正しく仏教的ではなくて正しくはないんですよ
はい 嘘をつかないという場合も例外の線を引くと
道徳そのものが崩れてしまいます
十悪 五戒などには実際
実は例外はあります 例外はあります
例外の設定も悟った人にしかできません
我々にはできません ブッダの遺言も結局は戒律を変えてはいけませんということです
ブッダ変えなさいと言っても
本当にには変えられませんということなんです
だからそれがブッダができることなら変えてみなさいと挑戦的に唱えたと思われる
小さな小さな戒律はね
まあ変えてもいいやと
あれ挑戦なんですよ それで阿羅漢たちが
では考えましょうと思ったら
もう手上がる 大阿羅漢たちにさえも
これが変えられません
では厳密に守ることに決めましょう
しかし 現代生きてる我々に負担かというと
全然負担じゃないんですよ
あ メスの動物と昼頃に乗ったあかんぞと
確かに例外のない規則はありません
英語の言葉さどりに例外のない規則はありません
ブッダの戒律にも見事に例外があるのです
しかし その例外もブッダ自身が定めるものです
はい 社会の中で調和を平和を保つために
個人の幸福を守るために決められる規則には例外もあります
よく戒律章に見えるのはディラーナッサアナーパティという言葉です
意味は病人には過ち 病人には過ちにならないんだ
例えば出家はこれこれやってはいけないと戒律たくさんあります
その戒律の中でよくたくさん出てきます
しかし 病人には病人は例外です
それで例外をきる一つの決まりなんです
はい 病気だから守れない規則もあるし
守ったことで病気は悪化する規則もあります
まあ例えば栄養の場合はね
食事っていうのはまあ午前中に終わりなさいとブッダが教えている
体がむちゃくちゃ壊れちゃって
手術されちゃって で 医者はその肉体を管理しなくちゃいけない
それで医者はこれ食べなさい
これ飲みなさいとかね
いう あ 戒律がやりませんって言っちゃうと死んじゃうでしょうに
その場合はディラーナッサアナーパティ
まあ病気だから過ちになりません
どちらかというと 命に危機が追ってくる時
ある規則を迫ってくる時
迫っている時 ある規則を無視しても良いことです
命が無くなっちゃうと
もうその規則をちょっとなんとか
例えばね 比丘が走ってはならないが
熊が襲ってくると走りますよ
戒律守ってやるぞと思って熊に殺されるというのは馬鹿馬鹿しいでしょうね
そういうのは例外なんです
比丘は女性に触れてはいけないが
誰もいないところで女性が溺れて死にかけている時はどうすればいいんですか？売り子
女性を触っちゃあかんから死なす？そんなのはもう例外なんです
わかりやすい だからすごいかっこいい例外でしょう
悪人なら殺してもいいからとんでもない例外なんです
あんなのは例外じゃないんです
殺すなかれ 絶対 例え虫でも例外なしと
あんた殺されるなって殺されるようになったら
だったら黙っていろと
逃げる 逃げるなら逃げろ
熊が襲ってくると逃げる
走る 人間が来てもう囲まって殺そうとするならばしょうがない
過去の業だとこって黙っていればいいんです
自分が人を殺さない それはもう例外はないんです
こういうのはかっこいい例外なんです
はい 例外は悪行為を緩めるためにあるものではありません
特権をある人に与えるために作るものでもない
例えば法律は国民が守るんであって
王様は守らないとイギリスの
断るでしょ 王様にはないと
そういうふうに誰かに特権を与えるための例外ではないんですよと
例外のおかげでより正しく道徳を守られるようにしなくてはならない
例外は何のためにあるかというと
もっと正しく道徳を守るためなんです
例外のおかげで 自分も社会もより幸福にならなくてはならない
例外が心を清らかにする努力を支えなくてはならない
それが例外を作る法なんです
例外を立てる法で はい
次に行きます  C 社会との調和
ブッダの戒律になくても
社会が決めた規則も守るのです
それが礼です ブッダが決めてなくても
社会がやるなよと決めちゃうと
仏教徒は守らなくちゃいけないんです
社会と喧嘩しない 国の法律はブッダの戒律に何の関係もないが
法律に従いなさいとブッダが説く
国の法律は戒律でもなんでもないんです
いい加減バカバカしい
しかし仏教徒は守るんですよ
なぜならば アヌージャーナと言って
ラージャにアヌワットとお釈迦様おっしゃっているんです
ラージャっていうのは王様のこと
あいつは言うこともできなさいよと
今は法律政府ですね しかし
人を生き物を殺せと命令されたら
たとえ自分が処刑になっても断るものです
ブッダが道徳に反しない人間の習慣文化などを守る
道徳に反しない限りの人間の文化をお祭りお盆とか仏教とやるんです
守るんです はい で 五番目
これはい終わります 理性
知恵と道徳は不可分離的なんですね Rationality,
wisdom and morality are integrated. 別れません
道徳は人をいじめてはなりません
というか 人をいじめるためにあるものじゃないんですよ
道徳はブッダの道徳は人に苦行させるために設定したものではありません
人の幸福をなくし 平安幸福を得るために定めたものです
不幸の原因は従って不道徳の原因も無知なのです
不幸の原因というのは無知なんですよ
不道徳の原因は無知なんです
道徳は無知を破ることを支える
ただ 無知を破るために道徳があるだけなんですよ
余計に人に人に苦行させようと思って全然思ってないんです
せっかくみんな楽しんでるのに邪魔してやるぞ
そんなこと仏教は考えてないんです
無知のせいで欲怒りが現れて感情的になる
理性を失う 道徳は理性的な人間を築く
例えば欲と怒りに出ていくと理性じゃないでしょうに
だから道徳守るといつでも理性でいられるんです
頭おかしくならずにすむんです
はい 次 で マジュリミッカイのこの四百ページ一番目のテキストにアパンナクすったっていうところありまして
理性に基づくなら道徳を成立するのだという立場が見えます
このアパンナクすったっていうのは疑問成り立たないって意味なんです
人は理性的に考えると疑問立たず
あの十項目は成立するんだよ
話にならないんだよという教典なんです
それでちょっとだけ省略したんですけど
転生があろうがなかろうが
道徳に価値があろうがなかろうが
業に結果があろうがなかろうが
そんなのわからないですよね
それに関係がなく 非道徳的な生き方でこの世で非難されるあの世があるならば
不幸に転ずる したがって
理性のある人は道徳を守る
道徳を守るために輪廻転生が信じませんだからそんな話になりません
輪廻転生がわかってもわからなくても
道徳破っちゃうとものすごく非難されるわけです
万が一将来があったら大変なことになるんです
だから守った方がいいという理性的な答えなんです
はい 次 知恵と道徳 道徳は知恵を完成させる
知恵は道徳を完成させる
仏教の道徳を守るために知恵が必要です
例えば嘘をつかないと言ったって馬鹿にできませんよ
かなり知恵を使わないと
結構大変です だから嘘をつかないという一つだけでも守ると
みるみるうちで知恵が開発されていくんです
そこで知恵がある人は自然に道徳
知恵があるんだからバカなことやらないんです
だからいつでもそれ総合的に離れません
仏教の道徳を守るために知恵が必要です
道徳を守ることで知恵が生じるのです
どちらでもいいんです
知恵があったら それで道徳な人間です
道徳を守ると知恵がある人間になります
はい 最後の章です 何のために道徳があるか
それは時間がなくて結構教わるんだったんです
だから何で道徳？何で道徳守らなくちゃあかんかと
はい それで即的な効果
社会から非難 批判されない
生きることはとても楽になる
日々人格が向上する 他人に信頼される
精神的に常に落ち着いている
すごいことです 心は正常になる
明らかになる 人の前で決して不安になったり
怯えたり 緊張したりしない
どんな人の前でも何のことなくおー見られます
すごいでしょう みんな緊張するんだから
面接なんかに行ったらどうですか？あの教師が
はい 知識と理性が育む
採算的なトラブル 予測しない病気などに遭遇しない
社会では指導者の位置になってしまう
道徳 何の自動的に指導者の位置になるんです
死後 確実な天界に生まれる
美しい健康な強情な体を持てる
今遅いかもしれませんだけど
まあまあ やっぱり道徳守るともうものすごい美しい体になります
あのヨン様みたい [笑い]どうかな
瞑想ができる 戒律を守ると
楽に禅定に達する はい
そうです これ出世間的な効果
簡単に煩悩を断てる 簡単に真理を発見できる
修行を修行ことを修行することは楽になる
解脱を経験でき 輪廻転生を乗り越えられる
涅槃という最高たる幸福を得るということ
これが悟りです 道徳守る
しかし 戒律を守ることは仏教ではありませんよ
道徳は仏教の最初の一歩に過ぎません
それを覚えておいてください
そんなに仏陀様が道徳論を語ったんだからといって
仏教が道徳論でありと言ったら
それは違うんです ちょっと一歩だけ仏教の世界へ
はい それでいい加減に終わるでしょうと思います
はい ありがとうございます
今日はお疲れ様です 酉年は私はこの鳥を見せたんです
あんまり食べられない鳥です
[笑い]